PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
Today what I want to do is
something maybe a little bit
more theoretical,
but the goal is
to show that
something that you are
going to be
repeatedly doing when
you use quadratic approximations
is, in fact, true.
So I'm going to
explain the situation,
give a quick example,
and then show you
what we're setting out to do.
So the situation is
as follows: we're
going to-- any time you
see a Q of f, that's
going to represent the
quadratic approximation to f
at x equals 0.
So what I've done
is say, Q of f I'm
going to define to be the thing
on the right, which is exactly
the formula you
were given in class
for the quadratic approximation
of a function f at x equals 0.
So f is approximately the
thing on the right near 0.
Our goal is to
show that if I want
to take the quadratic
approximation
of a product of two
functions, that I
can do it in a different way.
I can do it in the way written
on the right hand side, which
actually looks more complicated
in this notation, but is,
in fact, easier in reality.
So let me explain
what's happening
and then I'll give
you an example.
If I wanted to take the
quadratic approximation
of a product of two
functions, what I want to show
is that instead, I could take
the quadratic approximation
of each individual function,
multiply those together,
and then take the quadratic
approximation of what
I get as a result.
So let me give you
an easy example.
For instance, let's
let f of x equal
e to the x and let's
let g of x equal sine x.
Then what is Q of f?
Q of f is the quadratic
approximation to e to the x
at x equals 0.
And that's going to be 1 plus
x plus x squared over 2--
your already knew this.
And g, the quadratic
approximation of sine x,
is just x.
So if I wanted to find the
quadratic approximation
to e to the x sine
x, what I could
do-- what this is
claiming I can do--
is instead I can take the
quadratic approximation
of this function
times this function.
So instead I can take the
quadratic approximation
of-- f was the e to the
x-- 1 plus x plus x squared
over 2, times x.
That's not a 4, sorry.
That's a parentheses.
1 plus x plus x squared
over 2, times x.
And what is that?
The quadratic
approximation to that
is the quadratic
approximation to x plus x
squared plus x cubed over 2.
And at x equals 0, if
I have a polynomial,
the quadratic approximation
to a polynomial at x equals 0
is just all the terms up
to the quadratic term.
So I drop off
higher-order terms.
So I just get x plus x squared.
So that's the idea.
The idea is I have a
product of two functions,
I know their individual
quadratic approximations,
and so what I want
to do is I want
to find the quadratic
approximation of this product
by exploiting the
fact that I already
know their individual
ones, and explain
the fact that quadratic
approximation of polynomials
at x equals 0 is very easy.
So that's the example,
that's the idea.
So now let's see
if we can do it.
OK.
So we have a cheat
sheet up here that I'm
going to refer back to.
I didn't want to use it again
and I didn't want to have
to derive this for you, but
we have the product rule:
f*g prime is equal to
what's on the right,
and f*g double prime is
equal to what's on the right.
So my goal here is
to show, remember,
that the quadratic
approximation-- let
me point over here again.
The goal is to show the
quadratic approximation of f*g
is equal to the quadratic
approximation of quadratic
approximation of f times the
quadratic approximation of g.
So let's do, well let's do
the right-hand side first
because that's a little nicer.
And then we'll show
the right-hand side
and then we'll show
the left-hand side
and we'll show they're equal.
So let me start here
with the right-hand side.
OK?
So, let's look at what's the
quadratic approximation of f
and what's the quadratic
approximation of g
and then we'll take their
final quadratic approximation.
So Q of f, we have exactly
what we need there.
f of 0 plus f prime of 0 times x
plus f double prime of 0 over 2
x squared.
Q of g is equal to g of
0 plus g prime of 0 times
x plus g double prime
at 0 over 2 x squared.
So now what I'm going to do is
multiply those two together.
And I'm actually going to
swing this way a tiny bit,
if that's OK, to write
Q of f times Q of g
because it's going
to be a little long.
And I'm going to group
them carefully so
that I have all the
higher-order terms at the end.
OK?
So I'm going to
get f of 0 g of 0
by multiplying
these two together.
And then I'm going to get
two terms involving an x.
I'm going to get an f prime
times g and a g prime times f.
Actually, if you'll
allow me, we'll
know that anywhere
we see an f or a g
or an f prime or a g
prime, or an f double prime
or g double prime, they're
all evaluated at 0.
So I'm going to drop the
0's from here on out.
Anywhere you see those,
I'm evaluating them at 0.
Otherwise this will
be way too long.
So let me write
this just as f*g.
I can even write just a
single one evaluated at 0.
It's the product evaluated at 0.
And then I have f prime g--
so I'll just evaluate it
at 0 at the end of the product--
plus f g prime evaluated at 0.
This whole thing is times x.
I get an x here,
I get an x here.
Now I need to figure out what
terms give me an x squared.
OK?
So the terms that
give me an x squared
are f of 0 times g
double prime over 2.
That gives me an x squared.
f double prime times g
gives me an x squared.
And f prime g prime
So let's write out those terms.
I get f g double prime at 0 over
2-- from those two-- plus g f
double prime at 0 over
2-- from those two-- plus
f prime g prime at 0,
all times x squared.
So there's an x times an x
there, gives you an x squared.
x squared there,
x squared there.
Now I could keep
going, and I will
mention the higher-order
terms, but I'm not
going to write them all
the way out because of what
we're about to do.
Let me show you
where they come from.
You get an x cubed
term from here
and an x cubed term from here.
Maybe I'll write the x cubes,
but I won't write the x
to the fourth.
So the x cubed terms are f
prime g double prime 0 over 2
plus g prime f double
prime at 0 over 2.
And those are my x cubed terms.
And then I got some x
to the fourth terms.
And where do the x to the
fourth terms come from?
They come from this product.
Right?
But I want to point
out something.
What I'm going to do, I'm
going to work some magic
on the board.
This is a quadratic
approximation
of f times a quadratic
approximation of g.
Let me come over
here and remind you
that I want the quadratic
approximation of that product.
So what I'm going
to do is go back
and look at what
I need from there,
to be the quadratic
approximation of that product.
So we come back over here.
If I apply the
quadratic approximation
to this thing,
which means then I'm
applying it to this whole giant
thing, what do I actually get?
This is actually a polynomial.
I have something-- I have
a linear term, I have an x,
I have an x squared,
I have an x cubed,
I have an x to the fourth.
So if I apply that
quadratic approximation,
let's see what stays.
This term stays.
I'm going to erase what
disappears because I don't want
us to get confused by that.
So these two terms disappear.
Why?
Because again, this
is a polynomial.
I have linear-- or I
have constant, I'm sorry,
I think I called this maybe
linear earlier-- constant,
linear, quadratic term.
And what I need is just
those if I'm looking
for a quadratic approximation.
So constant, linear,
quadratic term.
I immediately drop the
cubic and the quartic term
when I'm looking at a
quadratic approximation
of a polynomial at 0.
So if I want the
right-hand side,
I just need what's
underlined in blue.
So now I'm going to put a big
box around that because that's
going to be important.
Whatever else happens,
we don't lose that.
So now we've done
the right-hand side.
And now let's write out
what is the left-hand side.
And that's just going
to be plugging it
straight into the formula.
And using our cheat sheet.
So Q of f*g, let me write
out the definition and then
we'll use the cheat sheet.
It's f*g at 0-- again,
this is f at 0, g at 0,
that's what this
notation means--
plus f*g quantity prime at
0 times x plus quantity f*g
double prime at 0 over
2 times x squared.
And now what we're
hoping, remember,
is that what's in the box
is what shows up over here.
Because this is the long
way to do the problem.
This would be if I took
either the x sine x
and I took all the derivatives.
And this, in fact,
even though it
looks more confusing
in evaluating
such a quadratic
approximation, this way
would be the easier way.
We just want to show we
don't lose anything by doing
what would be the easier way.
So I get f*g at 0.
And that's good-- we can see
we already have one of those,
so that's nice.
What do I get here?
I get f prime g at 0 plus
g prime f at 0 times x.
That comes-- let
me remind you, I'll
walk over here-- comes
from the cheat sheet.
The first thing.
f*g prime is f prime
g plus g prime f.
We know that one pretty
well, but just to remind you.
So that's where this
term comes from.
This looks promising
because if we come back
to our quadratic of quadratic
of f times quadratic of g,
it looks exactly like
the second term here.
So now we're hoping that the x
squared term looks like this.
The only thing that
might make you nervous
is this doesn't have
an over 2, but if you
were paying attention
to the cheat sheet
you'll probably see
where that's coming.
And I'll point it
out in one moment.
So f*g double prime,
using the cheat sheet,
is f double prime g plus g
double prime f plus 2 g prime f
prime.
I should have put 0's in there.
Just to be consistent let
me put these 0's in there.
2 f prime g prime at 0.
And then I have to divide
the whole thing by 2
because there's a
divided by 2 there,
and then times x squared.
So let me move out of
the way for a moment.
So this numerator came
from the cheat sheet
for the second derivative.
And if you need, we can go back.
Let me just remind
you, here it is.
You can work it
out for yourself.
You can just take the derivative
of the first derivative.
But that's where
this comes from.
So let me go back and we're
almost done with the problem.
So what do we see?
Well, we see that
we get f*g at 0.
We get the second term
we want, f prime g at 0
plus g prime f at 0 times x.
And then the third
term is, in fact,
exactly what we want because
we get f double prime g at 0
over 2 plus g double prime f at
0 over 2 plus-- the 2's divide
out-- and I get f prime g
prime at 0 time x squared.
And if we look at
this last term and we
look at the squared term
in the box we see, in fact,
they are exactly the same.
So let me summarize because
this was kind of a long video.
So I'm going to go
back to the beginning,
give you the example, and
tell you what we were really
trying to do here.
So let's come back over here.
And let me remind
you, the goal was
to show that if I wanted to
take a quadratic approximation
of a product of two
functions, if I already
knew their individual
quadratic approximations,
you were told that you
could take those two
quadratic approximations,
multiply them, and drop off
the higher-order terms.
The higher order than 2.
So we had an example.
We knew these two
quadratic approximations.
And you've been told that
quadratic approximation
of their product is just
the quadratic approximation
of the product of their
quadratic approximations.
And so our goal
today was to show
that you don't drop
any of the terms
that you get if you do it by
this method or by this method.
And we've done that.
So I think I'll stop there.